[Music]
this week we've got prize noodles solar
eclipse sacks and baby package
take it away today yeah so for our first
story there was this man who paid for
5000 bowls of spicy noodles as a
thank-you because someone turned in his
engagement ring that he was gonna give
to his girlfriend oh snap wait he just
had it in his pocket and he was eating
noodles and then he just left it there
yeah so he went to go eat at this one
restaurant and then he moved away from
his table leaving his bag there that had
a three carat ring holding huge I can't
afford a one carat ring pop how big is 3
carats I don't know it's double orange
long things I mean like what is a care I
don't know I'm a carrot handle gold I
don't know [ __ ] about diamond this one's
about a carat so like times 3 sighs so
what's the going price for something
like that yeah how much is it per carry
ah man that's a five digits yeah it's
five digits of five digits oh [ __ ] and
then it also depends on like clarity cut
a whole bunch of bull so it could be
like 10 grand 299 grand so this ring in
particular is worth forty four thousand
nine hundred that's a car that's a
[ __ ] car forty-four thousand yeah
damn Wow there's some ballers out there
at the noodle shop eating ramen yeah so
while he was eating you he walked away
to answer a phone call from his
girlfriend then in that time of course
is Chinese he is him he's actually oh
[ __ ] that's way hello
yeah he was just like so distraught
because he's like where's my bag with a
diamond ring but then luckily there was
someone that turned it into the manager
of that restaurant and their manager
gave it to him oh no that's a string of
honest people in China
yeah way to go China hey good job man
so the 5000 people helped them find it
no the thing is excuse me if anybody see
the diamond ring please come to the lost
and found
and give it to us oh my god this guy's
gonna get to marry and then they go out
and go hey did you see the diamond I
didn't see the diamond and they start
looking for it then oh my god happy
no it's like once they turned it in the
next day the man was just so happy and
grateful like he was able to get this
back and he wanted to do it like like a
good deed like paying it forward type of
thing so he went to that restaurant he
asked like how many bowls do you guys
usually sell in a day I guess they
answer five thousand cuz then that's how
much he paid for he paid for five
thousand bowls of soup and he said
invite everyone around to come eat some
free noodles that is nice Wow pass on
like the good deed so then other people
can know like what they do something
good then maybe you know their karma a
restaurant employee found it no only
like a lovely stranger well so in what
is the lonely stranger soundtrack sound
like that's a careless whisper but
there's a lonely street what the [ __ ]
cares not care I don't care [ __ ]
like is that what does that a careless
whisper I don't know I don't know I
don't know the lyrics of the song but I
like you too better than to cheat a
friend that's not a pretty good that
just sounds like a very neglecting quiet
sound but a lonely stranger I don't know
if the lonely stranger fell no they just
say a relatively stranger but then when
I translated the Chinese sight it said
that there was a little girl that found
it so I don't know oh you know little
kids have morals some of them do some of
the kids are sons of [ __ ] I take that
back I didn't have more
we got here's some photos of people and
get some free noodles I want is that
that way go back because we know when
agent people here free [ __ ] I think just
all minorities to be honest when they
hear free [ __ ] there's like a line so
I'm pretty I wouldn't be surprised of
all of this all the way back is that for
beef noodle soup because I see noodles I
don't know it's bondo I wouldn't be
surprised if half of them were
millionaires - you know what I would do
is that was my restaurant I would
actually I'll take that five dollars in
bowls that he paid for and then I would
sell all of those bowls and make double
the profit make money right no one's
turning in diamond rings at your
restaurant then you're what's wrong with
China and it's all fair game right no
cuz what if he's there would it be paper
wanted in your life you're selling it
you [ __ ] or he's not telling his friends
like hey you know I paid for all these
people okay that's you well I would know
which ones are our customers and which
ones are his friends how would you know
you know you would know if Shady's you
know put some in the pocket in that's
pretty dope yeah you spent $5,200 on
those noodles wait so it only cost like
a dollar it's a dollar now that's making
you hungry right now
that's some cheap-ass 40 grand in China
is like way more than here 300 thousand
yuan is how much of that ring was great
I guess it depends on their average
annual income because this person is
probably really ballin yeah I think what
Joe was talking about is like the
relationship so when we were thinking
about a $40,000 ring we're thinking
about an average price of $10 a meal and
right so that's 40 GS to attend dollar
meal here 40 G's to a $1 that's even
bigger that's like someone losing a
$400,000 a year yeah that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah that's a lot of money man oh
damn I wonder if she said yes oh she did
say yes any Chinese girl would say yes
how did what did she sound like
[Music]
you know answer already
yeah I can see they ended up posting a
sign in the shop saying I actually don't
know what it says but I'm assuming it
does something like this man found his
ring and he he's paying for all your
noodles better now but there's a sign
and I'm you could see like the photo of
the girl holding her hand with the ring
hello mr. Wang blue do you lose the big
diamond ring oh you found it oh my god
everybody knew those on the house all
right for our next story there's this
man that posted on Craigslist a really
interesting ad so the title says wanted
woman who wants to conceive child during
totality eclipse in Oregon
that's huge this year but you know
repeat that one more time she wants to
get calmed inside during the lunar guy
wants the kind of girl a guy wanted
woman who wants to conceive child during
totality eclipse oh he wants to have a
kid yes I'll read you a [ __ ] werewolf
he just wants [ __ ] he's shooting blanks
it says I am 40 years of age Caucasian
male from Europe my heritage is strong
and pure my looks instincts knowledge
and strength is a hundred percent pure
and a hundred percent full
I'd like to point out if you say my
heritage is strong and pure hmm that's
just another word for saying I come from
an ancestral family that means you've
been keeping the James within the family
for a century
that is nasty that's true I am looking
for were they with female with strong
jeans beauty and smarts to join me to
experience the totality eclipse in
Oregon exact place not set if we have
chemistry I would like for us to make
love while the eclipse is happening
bulking grows as soon as you see we're
gonna make love and I don't know you
[ __ ] that maybe you rather them say I'll
[ __ ] you yes okay she is a romantic
woman no cuz cuz there's no there's
there's no background right now like
don't tell me we're gonna make love when
I don't even love you we're gonna make
some bucks we're gonna fornicate
scientifically I'm gonna spread that
[ __ ] fine I know what I'm getting
into don't lie to me we're not gonna
make love I'm split the [ __ ] hairs a
nap it's a physical act when totality
occurs we will have simultaneous orgasm
orgasms predict Radames it's even
crazier cuz he that you won't have
simultaneous orgasm Yannick and that's
these states and we will conceive a
child so he's [ __ ] 100% or one time
but this was a virgin first of all it's
hard as [ __ ] to come at the same time
all right this whole say I'm gonna I'm
gonna restate this whole sentence cuz
it's just it's epic okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna retract a little bit they say
that European accent is when totality
occurs we will have simultaneous orgasms
and we will conceive a child that will
be on the next level of human evolution
Wow next dude wait so there's three
[ __ ] weird it has to be perfect right
yeah during the lunar eclipse totality
this hotel is Natalia quick or like yeah
that's always it's a huge one is that
what it's like completely black yeah
right but it's only like a small window
of time might use a minute two and a
half minutes so you got a time it to
where within that two and a half minute
mark
you're not only coming but you're making
sure that she's coming and at the same
time that
baby is for sure coming and he's gonna
be next level not only that but his
penis is gonna redirected somewhere oh
[ __ ] I guess the point of look into it
it's gonna be pointing to the [ __ ]
nebula stars there's more there's more
we will make love together which me and
my penis directed towards the cyanide
yeah with me and my penis directed
towards the Sun everything will be
aligned in the local universe both of
our cosmic orgasmic energy will be
aligned with the planets in a brief
moment of ecstasy we will understand
everything and together create a new
universe full of love
I think it's food Roland I don't think
this is right I hope not this is a
[ __ ] troll you must like cats drugs
are okay nitrix goodnight nitrous oxide
while we climax and experience totality
and conception is okay with me
wait so they're gonna be [ __ ] with
two big balloons like I feel like it's a
troll but I'm curious to see how many
people actually replied or he's actually
a California man near the San Francisco
area is where he posted this and I guess
he's planning to go up to Oregon during
this whole thing but within hours this
post is taken down damn it I wanted to
see you go down I want to see him point
his dick at the sky I want to see them
come at the same you want to see this I
want to see you because no it's like he
painted such a visual vivid picture that
I'm like man I don't even have
imagination like I want to see what his
idea of a pure genetically special man
looks like yeah I want to see the next
level human [ __ ] geek I picture a guy
like a ginger with hella sunspots
everywhere I'm just so curious if anyone
responded to it within those hours I
know I want to know hey there's just as
crazy like girls out there that would
[ __ ] really be into this [ __ ] yeah I
mean it's clever like it's clever like I
I'm like a little bit intrigued not for
this sex part but just to see what type
of person makes this post cuz he had a
lot of time to think of some really
creative [ __ ] if you guys haven't had
sex and
how would you reply to that [ __ ] no cuz
we're girls so we'll always have sex
yeah what have you doing we would always
and they didn't what we can empower
yourself you don't need some weirdo
random yeah peep that wants to make love
they don't have just physical
experiences and I learned that after 15
years if girls want dick
that took me 15 years to realize that
girls want dick they could go to skid
row and get dick at any time by the net
CD yeah but at least I'll still get dick
four guys will go to skid row and try to
hit on a girl still reject this yep yep
it's very we're not homeless enough are
you guys gonna try to see the eclipse on
Monday it's happening Monday it's a huge
deal yeah are people going to certain
places to see it better like like Oregon
or whatever there's like the first time
in 38 years that we have had a complete
like a totality type of eclipse where
the moon completely covers the Sun you
can just see like the corona of it the
first time in 38 years yeah fish it's
called the coal Rhoda yeah that's where
the beer name comes from exactly the
crown in Spanish Oh Gordo nice but um so
it's the first time in 38 years that
totality eclipse is happening in the
United States so it's like it's the
first time we can see it in 38 years
work like we're actually on the US soil
and we also like there's like a certain
path that crosses from like starting an
organ all the way down to I think it's
South Africa no no no just in the US
what that's a very long stretch being
tired but we can't see it yes we can't
see it this is the first time in know
Los Angeles in LA we can't see the
totality part of it but yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying is like the best vantage
point to seeing that is like organ in
certain cities yet it goes across the
entire oh you know I see pretty cool I
want to try to see it so we got to go to
Oregon on Monday I'm gonna hey yeah hey
road trip
what time is it happening depends where
you are but I remember when I was a kid
the they made us [ __ ] look at it in a
piece of paper but I try to look at the
Sun and it got mad I just remember we
had to like build like these cardboard
like goggles in hose
I remember that [ __ ] oh my god I thought
the kids were so stupid huh and you're
going with the burnt retinas no cuz I
don't like you can't see it like that
and then like we were there they wanted
us to see it on the reflection of a
piece of paper and I'm like [ __ ] that
I'm looking at that you know there's a
man that he was talking about cuz now
that the eclipse isn't happening he
burned his retina when he was a kid he
looked at it like so and I think he's 77
now or something like that but yeah like
he was saying like don't look at it
directly cuz i prime my right now duh
well obviously you're not supposed to
stay looking if it hurts your eyes that
guy's stupid no cuz it's the same
concept of like having a magnifying
glass and like pointing it you know like
having the Sun yeah pointing it to the
ground it's the same thing with your
retinas because it's acting like a type
of lens so if you later
burn it I looked at the Sun and it hurt
and I looked away I didn't stay I didn't
stay looking at it like a [ __ ]
Eclipse it's a once-in-a-lifetime chance
I didn't do that now I'm gonna try to
watch it online because like NASA at CNN
you can buy glasses too but there's been
a lot of things that help coming out and
even Amazon themselves recalls a whole
bunch of glasses cuz there's like a lot
of fake I'll buy the real ones oh and
then the fake ones can like magnifying
glass your eyeballs huh
yeah I don't think you're wearing
regular sunglasses gonna help don't
you're supposed to wear a special
glasses while looking at them even if
you're gonna take pictures of the Sun or
whatever you need like this what does it
do bérenger high man no no I mean filter
is an extra filter yeah it's like the
classic it's like a special type of
filter and they even saying that if you
have solar or Eclipse glasses NASA was
saying that make sure that they're not
older than three years and that the
manufacturers address is on there and
like there's like she could sue them
after when your eyes die no you just
gotta make sure you're getting legit
glasses and BC I just want to see like
I'm standing outside like a G just like
this one right and then I time it right
and I like see the eclipse happen it may
come into some money
oh that's a good idea as much Adams
being on I want to see the whole like
place become like dim
Oh even though we can see it online it's
like it's not the same as like the whole
world is dim and then it starts to get
light again versus like you're watching
the moon get in the way [ __ ] blocking
the Sun and going away right like I
could watch that online then effect this
way different in person yeah it's like a
basketball game so even though you have
like nosebleed seats the the vibe there
in the crowd going yeah like you can't
see [ __ ] and you're getting a headache
trying to watch these little ads play
basketball but the vibe is different
right
even though at home it's better to watch
it on the big screen yeah that's true
alright guys for our last story there
was this his mother this 24 year old
mother you [ __ ] [ __ ] I already saw
it on Tiffany's face Thank You Wally so
well why is she a [ __ ] she's 24 so she
said it she sighed and she closed her
eyes while she sighed so I'm like you
[ __ ] mom did you read that the 11th
Connection we have is that a girl
collection or is that like a Latin girl
collection did you or did you see that I
mean I kind of saw but it didn't really
register in my head cuz I see a girl's
in the circle you know it's in the
morning my eyes are a little hazy I can
only see that clear over there like
maybe the closer you are the more I
didn't even have to look at her face I
could just hear it I mean like the pret
you could the hora is close enough to
where you could you could sense it like
ah the energy yeah yeah so this 24 year
old new [ __ ] [ __ ] puta so what she
did okay honey
you're [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] for being
24 years old no why just why she's a
[ __ ] okay she you're 24 for being a
[ __ ] is she Mexican 24 is an insult
[ __ ] is a compliment yeah okay so what
she did was she wrapped her newborn baby
girl and plastic and she tried to mail
it to an oarfish oh that's so cute she
closed it too I'm not sure I'm not sure
exactly how it was packaged what country
is this
that's a shopping bag I hope there's
bubbles in there for the baby
it's baby girl maybe China China offer
oh is that the arrival destination of
where the baby the orphanage
I'm not sure we're like enroute she was
discovered but the the man handling the
packages he he heard a noise [ __ ]
Manhandler into it and he was like oh my
god there's a baby
anyway so the sort of Chinese mailman
picked up the package in a bit and the
package started crying pretty much I
would freak out if it started moving and
it's yeah and so they're saying that
that day it was it was 98 degrees that
day and there's like heat and so a
surprise that baby didn't die I know and
so as soon as they discovered that there
was a baby in there that's when the
mailman and like everyone around like
other residents like local nearby
residents they discovered that there was
a baby girl wrapped in there so they
immediately went to her care they got
like a bottle of water and they were
getting like Cotton's will drown it no
and they were trying to give the baby
girl at some waters that way can I see
that picture well she's a lot of hair
I'll show you guys the video wait like
duh how did he even get to the mailman's
hands like was it thrown into a mailbox
like how does that even happen I feel
like they might have dropped the girl
off in the post office and then you know
with like a whole bunch of packages and
that oh he was sorting air that's one
thing because like if they don't mention
her or he might have been to the like
the post box or the and then she was
picking it up and he was like what the
[ __ ] here we go look at that baby
wrapped up in that Burberry escort scarf
is that Burberry oh that's how my dad
wears his shirts in public I didn't
understand that either
he was just in shirtless hey dude it's
90 degrees in LA but it's humid
I don't know I said it's just different
what what's what's more important you
guys you can you guys if there's a
police officer that came on the scene
shirt was all Oh baby was like would you
guys get distracted I would in this
situation what I see that I'm Way more
distracted by that is I like to see his
nipples versus he's like restoring a
baby that's not true
no one you're you're Savage you know you
you yourself you're a barbarian so I
don't believe that statement do you walk
around in your underwear yes yeah but
not in public though what yeah not in
public
yeah I don't picture I don't picture
Bart rescuing someone in his underwear
of course I picture we go to the dog
park and he's already begging to take
his shirt off that's the dog park people
take off their shirts in the park
to get a tan wait no you don't know
where these people were they could have
been like just outside their house yeah
but it's not completely off that's the
funny thing
on finally button up your shirt
apparently the police were able to track
down who the mother mother is finish
please have shorts on oh no probably I'm
trying to figure out what this town
looks like it's throwing me off I just
see like everyone just [ __ ] all their
shirts are open just running around with
babies being mailed uv8 Oh you they
should call it fools town the cops track
down to the mom was and they returned
the daughter to the mother oh good
because that's what she was trying to do
she's gonna test that how quickly should
get her packages people social media
they were like they're criticizing the
cops decision obviously it's saying like
you know giving a baby back to a parent
so we can just abandon her again like
pretty good thinking is there such thing
as social services over there I know
right that's all see they probably just
don't want to deal with the situation so
they're like let her deal with it and
melody why couldn't she just personally
hand the baby to the orphanage like jet
to mail the baby and the other thing is
like she's so [ __ ] stupid that she
thinks the baby has it like can maybe
survive through the whole process
have to be survived or not or she's so
stupid that she imagined like the baby
going to the orphanage and then the
people opening up the package and the
babies like and it's all like a happy
scene in her head and she's so stupid
she doesn't think they're gonna track
her down cuz this baby has her exactly a
return address what if she wrote a
return address Bab did all that [ __ ]
full name
that's all they found her think about
search was really fun did I might pay
enough for the package return yeah pick
up bags you like [ __ ] did I not spend
enough did they mail it back to her nah
know what they are stupid yeah that's
true to give the baby back there so
nothing happens her in which she
received it there is no responsibility
taking getting arrestor nope she just
came out push her open and accepted the
baby maybe there's just too many babies
in China that's so so yeah you know like
in China apparently they don't like baby
girls I thought that rule was gone yeah
but it's still like they still don't
like baby girls well I mean I was doing
if they they're trying to abandon it's
also really expensive to raise kids out
there do they still have a limit on how
many kids they can have no they took
that away so you've got 50 now
but you get taxed like a [ __ ] oh
really oh damn Chinese baby tax damn hey
you guys want to stock any of us we'll
go ahead down to the description box
below and you can follow us on Instagram
and all kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]